ce bus a été acquis par le
musée Oracle de la villa d'este en 1992 et est une des
nombreuses éditions en bronze pour le
commerce réalisées par l'atelier du couple par la
société du zoo ou encore par d'autres
fondeurs anonymes c'est le témoignage de la popularité de La negras
une sculpture liée  à la
création de l'Afrique une des
figures allégoriques représentant les
quatre parties du monde réalisées par Kaboul
pour la Fontaine de l'observatoire de Paris
cette œuvre d'art a été réalisée
à partir de l'étude d'un modèle vivant qui
la situe dans le courant de la
sculpture ethnographique le  La beauté et
la force expressive du
visage de la jeune femme semblaient souligner
les sculptures. La conviction abolitionniste
qui nous est révélée sur l'écriture
sur le piédestal pourquoi naître esclave
au 19ème siècle l'écrivain français
Phil Phil Gucci était sensible à l'
émotion.  s'élevant de cette sculpture et
il a écrit lon sans œuf avec la corde
qui attache nos bras à notre dos augmentant
ta respiration s'élève vers le ciel la
seule chose qui reste libre pour l'esclave
le regard le regard du désespoir et du
reproche silencieux les utilisateurs appellent à la
justification protestation des chiens  contre le
Destin écrasant c'est une pièce d'une
vigueur rare où l'Icare
II ethnographique n'est dramatisé que par un profond sentiment
de douleur